la jolla california i'll be at the la
jolla comedy store august 5th through
the 7th philadelphia pennsylvania i'll
be there august 18th through the 20th
austin texas i will be there september
2nd through the third get your tickets
for those shows and all shows on my
website at ryanzigler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media and again thank you for
your support
uh if you're new here or if you've been
here i appreciate you and make sure
you're subscribed to the youtube hit
that subscribe set a reminder so you get
that episode video every tuesday audios
on monday all right if you gotta have
more hit that patreon it's five bucks a
month if you sign up for a year you get
over a month free you're getting a
honeydew a day early you're getting an
ad free getting it at no additional cost
we've released
i think 10 or 11 free episodes on this
youtube feed so you can see what they're
like and they are the wildest [__]
stories you'll ever hear in your life i
promise you that if you or someone you
know has a story has to be heard please
submit it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
and if i am in your town when uh
you're home and i'm on tour hit those
tickets up for the night pants nation
tour on my website at ryansickler.com
now that's the biz you guys know we do
over here we highlight the low lights i
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers and ladies and
gentlemen one of my absolute favorite
storytellers is back to continue his
life story please welcome back to the
honeydew y'all joey diaz welcome back to
the honeydew brother
i love it what's happening ryan sickler
everything is good my friend everything
is good
how do i look do i have to fix the
camera a little bit no you look great
you look great brother i love the
background you but you look healthy you
look good i know you're back out there a
little bit right now maybe that gave you
a little shot of [__] adrenaline up
in the arm you actually hit me up and
said hey let's do another one so i'm
glad i'm glad i know you're feeling it
good for you
and you say you know i wanted to say i
promised my daughter i called you and i
wanted to mention this
i'm in the bathroom brushing my teeth
and she's watching this cartoon called
big city greens on disneyland right and
i hear this
she's like dad come here and look at
this guy and she's like look at this
trick he's doing he's he's uh
swindling this guy and i'm watching it
and it's [__] you i go stella he's a
great friend of mine that's joey diaz we
watch the credits we call you oh she's
she goes you're doing jelly the ass
today i go yeah i'll do it she's like
can i listen i'm like you definitely
can't listen no you can't
love
dawg kids love that [__] show it's a
great book loves it my daughter uses
that as a whatever the [__]
the the statue of me
she uses it as a [__] i don't know i
don't know
yeah instagram avatar or whatever yeah i
love it it's great dude good for you
called me they called me and they were
like you know we want you to come down
i walked in there was a bunch of people
in there like reading rose [__] the
guy from
sons of anakin it was great it really
was great and i got a lot of traction
out of that role for the kids
that's awesome dude i love you got range
brother you got you're getting you're
getting killed on hbo and you're getting
uh resurrected on disney plus i love it
brother
what's better than 200 what's better
than i told the kid hey kid what's
better than a hundred dollars he goes
what i go 200
[Laughter]
my daughter and i say it dude it's great
man
so thank you for being back uh
let's get into it brother we left off in
1999 you were in the baseball movie and
you were stealing all their [__]
roller blades roller skates there was no
by the time the movie by the time i did
my role
which was a [__] line and a half
there was no roller skates over size
eight
like everybody would had [__] ingrown
toenails because they had to put on
small [__] roller skates they
couldn't figure it out
but i'll tell you what happened after
basketball because when you hit me up
with this i wanted to tell the story
because
listen i was in la for two years
and i was just a [__]
i was at the store
i was uh
you know making waves but i really
wasn't making waves i was having the
best time in my life doing coke and
being at the store and hanging out with
ralphie may
i mean that was if i was gonna starve
and struggle
that was the way to do it you know
so for two years i had been la just you
know finding my way and can i ask you
real quick is is basketball your first
movie role
first feature it is first of all big
in a couple short films whatever but
nothing with the magnitude of you know
[__] people opening doors for you and
people helping you with your shirt on
and all that [__] that's a feature film
you know so
after i shot that film i had a plan for
l.a and my plan
was simple i'm gonna stay in l.a
till i fail
like miserably
and then i'm gonna drive to colorado
kill my ex-wife and a husband and then
go to new york and spell coke until they
kill me
that was the [__] plan that is a sad
[__] plan but at that time i failed
at so many things
i was getting ready to fail like i would
i thought i would steal a microphone or
hit somebody in the head
and then it'd be all over for me steal a
bottle of booze like i was stupid like
that for years but when i got to l.a
and i got that role i remember driving
home from the comedy store one night
and you know like
i had to follow don marrero at the
comedy store i [__] hate it
because i couldn't follow every time i
had to follow dom it was the longest 15
minute drive ever to the store
and it was one of those nights when i
did well at the store and on the way
home
like i wasn't doing coke that night i
don't know what happened
maybe the colombians didn't show or
whatever
i was sober and i remember thinking to
myself joey you're on to something
you just
figured out a way to follow dom
i did really good behind them
and i got this [__] feature film
i don't feel like a criminal noble
i had done some crazy stuff these dudes
owed me money for a bet i put it at the
store i put in like this 800 bet with no
money at all
if i would have lost a bet i would have
had a deal with them at the store coming
down there and threatening me well i
went over there
and i borrowed a gun from my ex-manager
and i went over there and i got my 800.
they didn't want to pay me they were
like oh you have to leave a deposit and
then we'll pay you 200 i'm like what the
[__] are you talking about you know so i
was doing a couple things like that i
got into trouble at the store like not
in trouble i had pushed a guy
and we got into a fist fight and stuff
at that time i was known as a wild card
and i
didn't think
i would [__] make it people were
pulling rogan aside
and saying stuff to rogan all the time
that kid's crazy so
but that particular night i was like
wait a second
i'm a criminal i understand that i'm an
orphan i'm all these negative things but
i just followed don marrero at the store
after two years i figured out that
[__] puzzle
and i just booked a feature [__] film
this is from somebody who not thought
they would never even book an extra roll
because i wasn't good enough inside i
was like
i'm garbage i'm never going to book a
so when i booked it i pulled over and i
remember thinking to myself where tell
them cuz i know everywhere out here
where'd you pull over i pulled over and
found by the [__] gorky park by the
russian park yeah now it's white people
park but when i got to l.a it was a
russian park people sold nickel bags
down there and [__] that whole
neighborhood was rushing i lived there i
lived off of poinsettia for a little bit
by rock and roll ralphs
oh yeah we were all there at 98. ralphie
me doug stanhope mitch hedberg nick
depala all of us live
in that curson
uh vista
area sierra bonita
so i remember just pulling over and
thinking to myself i can't believe i'm
doing this
like i was whoa
stop the presses
a [__] convicted felon who's
basically a criminal
just booked a feature motion picture
okay
we're on to some for the first time
in my life i've got the second baseman
son
so it really made me think of what was
going on at that time
so i had a couple negatives you know i
was homeless i i had a [__]
girlfriend that i loved with all my
heart but it was just a [__] problem
being with her
it was a [__] problem being with her
i was with her for five years and it was
never
[__] ending
and i loved her that she had good [__]
she would do things she put bottles in
her ass you know she did anything sexual
that you asked you know she was the real
deal
i'm god's father to her first son after
we broke up
i'm still friends with her you know i
still
call her and torment her you know you
got an old [__] and all that [__]
but she had no
she had to go
the cocaine wasn't going anywhere
that that was accepted already but she
had to go it was just
too many [__] headaches i decided at
that point josh wolf had given me a car
did we talk about that already i think
so was it the one about you guys all
borrowed it and you you ran the [__] out
of it some old manager's car or
something i think it was yeah yeah
10 000 tickets and all this [__] very
sad but
that car got towed
you know and it was a big joke that my
apartment got towed because i lived in
the car you know ralphie and all those
guys your apartment got towed so
they told everything from me
and
i was broken like this is one of those
tests
la put you through and anybody who's
watching this you're all going to be put
through this test it's things are going
really good in your career but things
are going horrible in your personal life
this happens and you have to figure it
the [__] out because if not you'll lose
them both
you'll lose the career
and you'll lose whatever you got going
on in your personal life whatever
there's a mom a wife a brother who's
aggravating the [__] out of you
once that car got towed i was lost and
i went to that girl's house that's where
it got towed
at her house we had broken up
and i went up there to give her a
stabbing like three weeks later and sure
enough
the bad luck from her ran into me and my
car got so
i'm like now whatever thoughts i had are
[__]
they're cemented
they're [__] cemented you know i got
to get rid of
so
about a month later
her and i would break up for a month
and then we'd go back with each other
then we'd break up then we'd go back
she called me we were gonna get together
and i ended up buying like a [__]
like a brisket
i spent like i had like 60 bucks you
know when you're a comic you got 60
bucks and this is it there ain't no bank
account
dad's not sending me a thousand on
monday you know i had 60 bucks
and i liked her and i told her this i
got 60 bucks don't [__] with me so she
goes let's go shopping and have a nice
meal
so we ended up and i bought like a
london bra whatever the [__] you follow
those big pieces
yeah
and
before we even we get to the supermarket
we get home
i remember was a sunday and it was like
uh
90 towards the end of 98 and it was like
a sunday and
before the [__] dinner was done we
got into it we just got into a
heavy-duty [__] brawl
and the brawl the argument went on to
the street
you know
and it was like you know i'm done with
you you know we were just arguing that
breakup argument you know [__] you [__]
you i want you out of my heart all this
[__] and finally she got mace
to spray me with mace on the street
and i had the roast beef in my hand
whatever the [__]
[Music]
and i'll never forget being on in
hollywood
on [__] you know one of those side
streets vista another one down from
vista and her and i are in the middle of
the street on a sunday at two o'clock
arguing and she shoot me with mace and
i'm swinging the roast beef at it
you
know i don't know in the street dude i
got to be 36 37 at that time you know
and i was starting to get
a little self-aware you start to get a
little self-aware as you get old like
what the [__] am i doing you know
and i swung at her with the [__]
roast beef and mister
and then i just stopped
and i go what the [__] are we doing
what is this
i'm 37 years old
i just finished a [__] movie the
biggest movie of my life i'm at the
world famous [__] comedy store
and i'm fist fighting with a girl in the
middle of the street on a [__] sunday
she shoot me with mace and i'm swinging
at her with a roast beef blocking my
eyes that
i've done a thousand things that was not
gonna work and i'll never forget i told
her to go [__] herself and i just turned
around and walked up the sunset
with my
thirty dollars my roast my uncooked
roast beef
and i brought it to ralphie mays
he cooked it with a mace on it
oh man
holy [__] i brought you
he was all excited let's cook it up
you know so we cook
i was talking i said i gotta wait
she kept
i had a pager that i didn't even have a
cell phone i had a pager and she kept
paging me she's gonna [__] have a
brother kill me whatever stupid girl
[__]
and i'll never forget when i ate i
called joe chadwick in miami improv
and i go joe i'm in a [__] bind i got
to get the [__] out of here do you have
any work for me and he goes
i don't have an emcee the next six weeks
i said i'm the new house mc
at the miami improv and i got in the
plane i got away from that [__] wench
i got on the plane and i went down there
and worked my material bought clothes
because they told everything
my clothes my sneakers my everything
warm-up suits headshots vhs tapes and i
couldn't untold the car because i didn't
have the registration
so they wouldn't even let me get in the
car to get my [__] those [__] suckers so
i had to stop from scratch
so i would go down there snork coke work
out and buy clothes that's all i was
doing i was doing every show i could the
black shell
everybody was giving me work and after
about eight weeks i had about fifteen
hundred dollars and i came back to l.a
now it's 99
i'm living with a friend of mine i'm
living on ralphie's couch
celine's couch
got rest his soul god rest his soul i'm
living on
all these couches on 1440 north garden
i'm doing stand up i don't even know
where i'm gonna sleep
i mean it was such a renegade
[__] life like
just going to do stand-up at the store
and not knowing
where you're going to end up at night
some nights i'd end up at a black chicks
house
in beverly hills snort and coke
some nights i would end up at a [__]
party some nights
i would sleep in a car some nights i
would
go into 14 ford they'd be like two weeks
i'd have a bet
because a lot of comics lived in 1440 so
they leave town and i picked their lock
and i just sleep on their bed for a
[__] week
ralphie's bed selene bed
gentry's bad and then after i got my
[__] together i said i'm still not ready
for l.a
i to you know i was nelly i was fighting
for like two years and beside that uh
that car getting towed and me fighting
with the girl i [__] ate a bag of
dicks one night following doug stanhope
at the improv that freaky monday one of
the biggest [__]
shows of the week industry out the ass
doug stanhope goes up there before me
and decides to say
it's easier to jump over a [__] than a
black guy but he didn't say the word
black guy he said the word and the
[__] place
like it was a black knight what do you
expect them to do
chris tucker was in the audience and he
goes get that [__] white boy off the
stage wow holy [__]
so now he gets off the stage coming to
the stage joey diaz i woke up that's
what you gotta go after ah
i walked up there to crickets more
crickets and dead crickets i didn't get
a [__] giggle in 10 minutes
i left there i walked out the door i
think i i fried myself home how can you
bomb on a monday night that that's so i
was like [__] it i'm not going back
till i make sure that's never going to
happen again
so i basically went to miami came back
hung out with ralphie for a few weeks
and i talked this girl jody she had a
car
into going back to basics
even though i was a
regular at the store
even though i had done movies i had also
booked the taco bell commercial like i
had a calling there i had a [__]
opportunity there
i went on a triple run
yeah i won an eight-week trip damn
which turned into a 20-week run are you
[__] you're driving all those spots
and doing that dog when you do comedy
you do comedy when you know how to get
better there's a way that you just go
i'm gonna get [__] that much better
so i did the tour started in november
and i did not you didn't come home in
those days it wasn't like you came home
like tom and showered and went back out
thursday didn't have the money
you have the money you had the money to
fly back
and not fly to the gig the following
week or
you had the money to stay in the hotel
that was it eat subway sandwiches veggie
and cheese and anything else you could
[__] get for two dollars
so i stayed out from the beginning of
november
to like april
29th damn
and that takes the goal that's in the
2000 now right
so now we're into 2000 okay you're out
on the road for the first four months of
i started a tour with a girl that was a
party machine
she doesn't even do comedy more great
great friends we still talk i'm tight
with her and her sister
we went on a [__] every night we
would drink a bottle of tequila
a bottle of this liqueur and beers
and if we got coke we got coke if we
didn't we didn't
it started at the eighth ball in
in idaho
and the doorman
the doorman was a girl
and i asked her she'd get eight ball and
she goes absolutely
and she did get me some fantastic coach
she brought to the hotel room
she was hotter than [__] and then she
goes do you mind if i fix
i go what are you talking about yeah
okay
he goes i'm gonna fix in your room she
[__] fixed with coke in my room
she did some needles and then we [__]
around a little bit
she goes don't tell nobody i'm not gonna
tell nobody you know i'm not gonna judge
you but that's the first night that i
thought that just goes to show you
that's how it kicked off yeah
that's how it kicked off
oh you know we were drinking kawaka
oh i remember that [__] yeah yeah yeah
oh we
and we did this every [__] night
this tour was only supposed to be until
like march
but then i got a call from miami improv
and me and this girl went down there for
three weeks jesus
i headlined one week and i featured two
weeks and she didn't see two weeks
we headlined for dave chappelle
yeah
there's still a picture at the miami
improv me dave
and jody sitting there stoned to the
[__] guilds
but i went on a hell of a [__] tour i
went from
idaho all the way to miami
and all the way back to texas to el paso
and the tour ended in el paso and i was
done
i came home in like may of 2000 and uh
that's la back to l.a in may of 2000.
okay
i moved in a friend of josh wolfe put me
up in this house gavin
i paid him like 200 a month to sleep on
his couch and again i was just living
the [__] wildest life like it was
just
comedy no working out no walking no
eating carrots
there was no drinking water
you know you're making 300 a week i'm
making 15 a spot i mean whatever they
give me at that time i used to eat a
wendy's junior cheeseburger every day
for a dollar they had the dollar menu a
bowl of chili and a salad that's what i
was living off and then
cocaine
and comedy like a [__] eating
all the fruit up at the store
i read a book that kennison and carla
beau used to go up there early and eat
all the fruit to make the drinks
so i started eating the [__]
okay i see the olives and all that [__]
i'm getting a full balanced meal up at
the store
it's really crazy when you think of
those times like i was just in love with
comedy
like there was no women at that time
like that time i said i got an
opportunity to do this
forget being a criminal anymore but i'm
going to tighten everything up
i'm going to type my life up i got to
get rid of this girl and i got to really
tighten up my [__] comedy game
and that's what i did that [__] so
when i got back in may
i just went kicking it up at the store i
started auditioning again
and it felt really [__] good you know
i couldn't keep living how i was living
there was a girl on sunday nights who
would come to the comedy store
and we would do dmt what's not the mt
the [__] that you drink
ghb uh
yeah i know what ghb is
we would drink that [__] and go back to
a house and do drugs
valium and i would wake up on monday
morning
at her house all [__] up we'd spend
the night together
it was just uh the life i wanted to be
honest here you know when you read
ladies and gentlemen lenny bruce
yeah he's a [__] wild man in that
book
anybody who reads that book and doesn't
want to do comedy you're a [__]
[__]
because
that that book will make you do comedy
even if you're a deaf mute
you're like what hang out with strippers
get my dicks up hang out of the
burlesque club and do crack stupid jokes
that's great comedy and that's the life
i was living guys and it was scary
but god always has a plan
life can be overwhelming and many people
are burned out without even knowing it
symptoms can include lack of motivation
feeling helpless or trapped detachment
fatigue and more i know when i'm burned
out i feel like so i feel sorry for
myself i don't eat right you know i'm
tired all the time uh you know i and and
i just feel like i've hit a wall we
associate burnout with work but that's
not the only cause any of our roles in
life can lead us to feel burned out and
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to prioritize yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
you know that i'm a big believer in
therapy
um
i just you know i see everyone's always
worried about how they look and not
about what's going on in their mind you
know get that gym going on in your mind
okay better help is customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
and you can be matched with the
therapist in under 48 hours honeydew
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month at betterhelp.com
honeydew that's better h-e-l-p-com
honeydew for 10 off your first month
when you know more you can do more what
if you could use science to discover
more about your body find out what you
need for healthier tomorrow with everly
well everly well is digital healthcare
designed for you an affordable and
transparent price with over 30 at-home
lab tests you'll be able to choose the
test that makes the most sense for you
to get the answers you need everly oil
has high quality vitamins and
supplements to support your overall
health including vitamin d3 and omega-3
fish oil here's how it works everly well
ships products straight to you with
everything needed in one package simply
collect your sample and use the included
prepaid shipping label to mail your test
back to a certified lab your physician
reviewed results get sent to your phone
or device in just days you can even
share the results with your primary care
physician i've taken multiple tests now
and again food sensitivities i found out
never knew i had man it's so simple over
1 million people have trusted every well
to support their health and wellness
goals and you should too for listeners
of my show everly well is offering a
special discount of 20 percent off an
at-home lab test at everlywell.com
honeydew that's everlywell.com
honeydew for 20 off your next at home
lab test
everlywell.com
honeydew now
let's get back to the do
so towards the end of the month in june
i was walking into the store
and i was walking into the original room
to check in
in 2000 you had to check in
with the sound girl you know in the in
the original room
and as i was walking up the steps i saw
this girl with blue eyes and we just
caught eyes
and it was
that those catches where even as i
turned around
i kept looking at her
like it was like a weird feeling she was
a pretty girl but not enough for me to
fall over my cell phone
but i noticed that we were we just
locked eyes we were just looking at each
other you know
so i think the next night i was there
and she was there she was a waitress
and i started talking to her a little
bit and she started talking to me you
know
i was an animal at that time and i had a
reputation as an animal at the store you
know
and i remember about that time right
when i met her like the week that i met
my wife
i got into a fight up at the store
some guy said that i was only funny
because i was doing coke
before my set
if anybody knows anything about me
i respected the hell out of comedy i did
coke
my first year in comedy i wasn't even
doing comedy a year and i was saying
patty's day in boulder i decided to do a
couple lines
and go on stage and it really [__]
i didn't do well so i go mental note i
don't know what richard pryor was
talking about you can't do coke and go
on stage you know richard never did
pokemon on stage but in my mind he did
so
i got so pissed off at this kid
that he was talking to me from like six
feet away and i was in the building in
the back door
and he was over here and like i'm
telling you guys i was buck wild then
and i just threw a bottle at him
i thought you were gonna say you charged
him
dog
he was standing next to another comic
that's well-known
and it didn't even faze me at all
i had a heineken bottle and i just
whipped it at him and he [__] ducked
and the bottle hit the wall and they
[__] ran out of there and i chased
the guy you know he ran i was 400 pounds
i wasn't gonna catch him but i made my
[__] point
it was funny the next night when i was
headed to the store i was at a light by
coaching horses
and the well-known comic he was with saw
me and ran up to the car he's like hey
that was not with me last night that was
the comics of such [__] you know he
was laughing at the joke when he said to
me but now it had nothing to do with him
because i threw a [__] bottle on his
head you know
and then that [__] dude
he used to be a guitar comic
all right i'm not gonna mention any
names
and he when he got past he was a guitar
comic
so one night mitzi went in it was the
only night missy went in and david tower
was there and this [__] jerk off goes
on stage without the guitar
and he dies a slow death
and just as he's leaving mitzi grabs him
and goes listen i better not see you on
the stage without the guitar again oh
[__]
so now
we're outside two hours later an hour
later the guy's like [__] mitzi
[__] her she doesn't know what the [__]
she's talking about
now i love betsy shaw
i loved like a mother at that time you
know
and
i would have stabbed this mother like
i'm like look at this dumb [__] you know
she's been doing this for 30 [__]
years
and she's developed stars but he's out
here saying that mitzi's a [__] and all
this [__] and he's given names of people
who went away from the store and became
all this famous [__] so he left the
store
six months later i see this [__]
at the the room that dane cook became a
star at dublin
dublin
and i see him like hey how you doing i
got a couple drinks in me
i got a couple bumps in me you know me i
don't like the guy as it is but what he
said to me
so now i got to drop some knowledge on
him hey how are you doing he goes great
he goes yeah i'm going to call into the
store i'm going back to the store i go
dog i don't know if you've spoken to
mitzi lately
but your guitar ain't gonna work you
better show up with a three-piece
[__] band you better come in with a
drummer a saxophone you better come in
and he got pissed because he was a
shitty comment and you know for him to
say to me that we snorted coke or
whatever so i just [__] chomped him
at the bit this [__] like when
you come back
you better bring a big [__] bang
because she's not gonna let your back in
there
so he came back to the store one thing
got tough and this chick that i like the
waitress came over
and she's like [__] this [__]
you know do what you want
and i started talking to this chick and
we started talking all night and then
it was july the 3rd
i had a gig in lake havasu
so she goes are you coming now are you
ready to go home and i go yeah thank you
for talking to me she's like what are
you doing for the fourth i go i got a
gig and have a suit and i don't have a
ride i got to figure out how i'm going
to get there
and she goes i'm not doing nothing i'll
give you a ride
just give me gas money she's my wife
today hell yeah
hell yeah that is all we did
we just had our anniversary fought the
july weekend so yeah yeah congrats
brother how many years
22. [__] yeah man congrats
so i was a savage at the store you know
light my balls on fire having a great
time
but uh once i met my wife it was all
over this and i didn't even know she's
gonna be my wife you know of course yeah
but we had to keep it under a hat for a
long time because mitchy sure didn't
want you
dating the employees
so we couldn't tell anybody
and one night we went food shopping
about a month afterward and eleanor
sauce
at ralph's and she's like what the [__]
is this
you guys date we're like yeah we're
dating
and then we were just dating and again
she was so nice
i didn't really want to date her
like do you know what i'm saying yeah
she was a nice girl
she was too nice of a girl for me so i
just
i kept the arms distance
you know
i would take her out on dates and [__]
like that but when i was at the store
i would just try to be cool and get her
out of there i didn't want him mixing in
my other world you know
but it was really funny that
she was so [__] sweet i didn't want
to date her like at all ryan i was
trying to stay away from her after a
month i'm like i can't be with this girl
i'm just going to do something stupid
and she can't handle it i don't want to
hurt nobody you know i had already been
married and divorced
and right now i wasn't looking for a
girlfriend i was just looking to do
comedy to [__] and suck and snort coke i
didn't want
nobody to you know what i'm saying
i want a [__] girlfriend like i want
to [__] hold my hat so
i [__] avoided her a lot you know
and then one night i was going to new
york
at like it was like august
we had been together about a month and a
half i was going to new york and i
didn't go to the store the night before
i had like maybe twenty dollars
to go to new york with i had the money
for the ticket
and for twenty dollars i was gonna mooch
off my brother when i got here
and she [__] just showed up at
ralphies at two in the morning
and she's like why haven't i seen you
they're like i've been busy
you know and she's like let's hang out
come over and i went over to her house
and she's like how you get to the
airport and i go i have no [__] idea
so she goes i'll give you a ride we
stayed up all night
and then at the end of the night i'll
never forget this she goes do you have
any money and i go yeah i got 20 bucks
and a couple cigarettes and she goes
take my cigarettes
and take my 40 bucks she had made like
50 bucks the night before
at the comedy store as a waitress and
she goes
take that money i've never taken money
from a woman before like that's not even
in my realm you know what i'm saying
i'll rob a [__]
you know i rock i robbed a couple
[__] in my day
i robbed the chick once i met at the
comedy store i was eating a [__] and
i'm trying to take the money out of her
pocket
when she picked me up and i didn't pick
her up with the comedy store i picked up
at the
she got thrown out of laugh factory
because she was heckling comments
so when i got when i was leaving she
comes up to me she's like were your
feelings hurt i go no i didn't even know
you were there
and we start talking she's pretty cute
and she goes do you want to go get a
drink and i'm like yeah let's go get a
cocktail somewhere
we didn't find i didn't know any bars
you know i'm not a drinker so i didn't
know any bars
so i said let's just go to a liquor
store oh my god ryan sickler
we went to the liquor store she brought
bob levac and when she went up first she
took out a [__] gangster roll
like that hundreds of gas station wild
cats
my dog this [__] is going down right
i had like a gram of coke maybe a little
less
i'm doing lines with it i'm looking at
that quad i'm like ah
i already called dante i'm like dog i
got a pigeon what time he closed he's
like one i'll be there before one
this chick was staying at a japanese
restaurant at a japanese hotel
downtown
she was working for a computer firm and
they put her up for a seminar
so she goes if you want we can go back
to my hotel and finish off that coke and
[__]
so we get back to the hotel we're
finished we do a couple lines you know
she goes let me slip into something more
comfortable whatever the [__] like how i
don't even know she put like a top on
that's what it was because she had like
a tight thing with [__]
with her tits popping out so she put on
like a bed thing but she had her jeans
on her shoes
and we start swapping spit and she stops
and she goes i have a boyfriend uh
i'm gonna be so like patna it's like
when you do a virgin catholic girl on
the walk home you got to pet that back
they're crying like
i'm going to go to hell now no you're
not
going to forget
so
[__] times we're swapping spit we're
not even doing nothing heavy
and you would break away and go i got a
boyfriend i feel so guilty i'm like
where's your boyfriend he's like in
seattle so [__] don't worry about it
what's your man got to do with me i got
a man that's right i'm about to hear it
you know what i'm saying yeah i remember
that song
though
one thing leads to another finally i
told us i want to lick your [__]
monkey and she can't
she can't take it so i take a little
jeans off and i'm watching that bulge
but what she did what she did to me was
that she took the gangster roll she took
the singles from the middle and she put
the singles on top now that made the
gangster roll a jewish role
so eating a [__] and i'm trying to
pickpocket right
and i'm taking out singles i'm like what
the [__] and a [__] had sweat to it so
it smelled kind of weird it was like a
fear factor type of [__] fair [__]
meat the satsiki [__] it tastes like
that the gyro sauce it's got that little
greek smell to it i mean [__]
i close my nose without the fingers like
i'm trying to like knock my feet
digging in my [__] with my tongue
but the whole time i'm trying to
pickpocket a
10-minute feedback episode i finally got
it for 200.
i shot my head
put a quarter in the meter
this is the funniest story ever
i
[__] get in that car and i shoot to
dante's house the drug dealer it's five
to one i just made it i go in i go
here's 200 give me 200 worth of coke he
goes you owe me 50 from the other no
worries
also he looks at me goes you smell funny
and i go yeah i was eating some old
greek [__]
it smelled like something out of jimmy's
seafood
it smelled like a clock heavy state food
but i ate it
but i popped out of there like a savage
the next day i had some cancer sauce and
[__]
i lit you know what i'm saying
if you eat [__] and you get a canker
sore that's not good
but every once in a while you get a
batch of bad [__] it's like a bad
tomato it's like a i know what i'm
saying
[__] so did you go back did you go back
are you out of there no
[Laughter]
he was really cute i think she was a
vegan vegan chick said [__] smell
because women need meat when they don't
eat meat because he has wang in the deep
one
deep in the middle deep deep in the
middle when you're fingering it before
the flies come out
it's got that little wang in there
you have like a girl intern right now
my producer she's curtis
i didn't know flies came out yeah you're
not looking
[__] boning and
[Laughter]
i went back to new york i
was only home for like three days and
when i got back
she picked me up at the airport
and we started talking and she goes why
don't you just come to my house
for a few days and lay low there and
relax i wasn't feeling good and i'll
never forget
she goes uh if you want you could stay
here a few days
why don't you go pick up some clothes
and i go what are you talking about
this is it
these are mommy these are my clothes
like four pair of jeans
four t-shirts maybe like a nice shirt
socks
no underwear i didn't wear underwear
then because it's either cocaine or
underwear
oh you gotta make up your mind you gotta
make up your mind you can't have both
it's either cocaine or [__] underwear
get it together
[Laughter]
i think you [__] have a good call
though you don't need underwear if you
have pants you don't see that you don't
need
you got to work on what you got when
you're a coke fiend you got to work with
what you got
oh [__]
okay
so you're staying you're gonna stay at
her place
yeah she asked me to stay with her and
i felt really shitty
because i i thought like this is gonna
end bad now i'm living with it you know
so the whole time i was with her those
first two years i was really protecting
her and we were both in the same place
she didn't know about my addiction she
had an idea
she was coming off drinking she wasn't a
big drinker but she didn't like drinking
because it made a blackout and stuff so
we were both coming from the same place
we were both [__] broke as [__] i
mean
her rent was 700 rent control in
hollywood and
i could barely make my 350.
you know i was always have to borrow
money from ari or joe
just to make rent you know but
it was so weird she had a cat
and the cat
didn't like me but then
after a year
the cat started liking me and it was so
crazy i used to come home for the cat
like i never had than that you know like
i never had a life at this point since i
was 16. now i'm 37 and i'm finally in a
relationship that i really liked her
i really respected her because obviously
i don't want to do [__] like i never
broke cocaine at that house
i always did it outside and ran into
[__] inside but i never did cocaine and
the night i didn't do cocaine we'll get
to later in one of the few episodes but
i don't know it was uh
it's it
me living with her made me
respect her home
so i stopped acting like a savage at the
comedy store
and
i started taking auditions a little bit
more seriously
i think the first thing i booked after i
moved in with her was like uh
mad tv
and then uh i booked uh a chaz mom and
terry movie
called women versus men
and i'll never forget like we got like a
check for 600 bucks
and our first dinner together was at
that sizzler
like we were going to [__] sizzler
guys like
sizzler to eat those sizzler cancer
shrimps
those little [__]
those little katrina shrimps
that was it guys
[Laughter]
me and this girl lived in a one bedroom
studio god
you know we slept in the closet
we both smoked cigarettes you know we're
both sharing cigarettes i mean let me
ask you a question
because also you and i have one thing in
common at from 16 on i have no parents
myself i'm raised by the streets raised
by the wolves you know i i feel it
genuinely has put me
behind i always
think it's about ten years uh i i have
i'd love to say i have a [__] masters
in
street smarts and
normal [__] i feel like i'm stunted and
it's things i still need to learn and
grow that other people had parents have
told them right
so at this point now where you're sort
of calming down do you start to feel
um maybe part of a unit like part of a
team a family so to speak you said you
started coming home for the cat and i
get that with my dog i'm like i just
want to go home and kick it with the
[__] dog and pet on the dog you know
what i mean like do you start to feel
like you had something to belong to you
know or a place to be
what what do you attribute that shift to
you know i was getting sick and tired we
all get sick and tired
we get sick and tired of situations
we're in we get sick and tired of
relationships we're in you know
i was sick and tired of relationships i
was in i was like in a
since the time i got divorced i had been
in a
my
my love life was hard it was a sex life
and i didn't enjoy it i mean we all love
[__] we all like eating ass and putting
coke on a chick's [__] and eating it
you know we all loved that [__]
but
it was getting old it felt empty
you know i didn't have a girlfriend in
boulder i had a couple girls and they
would only come over to do coke
and [__] and suck and then they went
home and gotten i wouldn't hear from
them for a week then they would call
again
you know so it was like
i didn't want a relationship but it was
nice just to have
a nice girl
around
she was just a nice irish girl you know
that's the other thing
i always dated irish girls when i was
growing up and i had no problems
you never have a problem with an irish
girl when an average girl picks a crazy
[__] they're a match made in
heaven because
irish fathers are crazy
so they're used to it
irish girls will take anybody i love
them i love them with all my heart even
my friendships where women are irish our
relationships are off to a different
they know i'm crying the lady around the
corner is an irish pharmacist
right she's a pharmacist the cbs the
head pharmacist genius of a woman her
and i talk every [__] day she got two
kids me her husband drove me to do
comedy that night
but her and i have a genuine bond any an
irish woman in me we go we could take
over the world
and that's what happened with this chick
like
she was irish and
she was my girlfriend and i had
gotten away from irish girls
since i left north bergen
but when i was a kid i dated the mcneils
the [__] morans
i loved irish girls you know like
colleen mayne's that's the one that told
me her mother died like i couldn't date
no more because whose mother dies when
you're five what the [__] did you do
and now i feel bad i should reach out to
her because i dumped her because her
mother died so when my mother died i
thought about that because i was like
who the [__] i don't want to hang out
with nobody ain't got a mother what the
[__] kind of person are you
so i always hung out with rock paper
scissors i really thought of that wow
yeah
so i'm an irish woman i love italian
woman i love black women i love spanish
women but the ones that'll tolerate my
[__]
and under when i say to somebody i'm
going to stab you in the in the eye with
a knife most women will run an irish
girl to go joey put the knife down come
on
[Laughter]
hey those
get in the [__] house what i'm saying
what's the matter with you out here
yelling like a [__] wreaking you know
what the [__] so
all those things contributed to it as
much as i didn't want a girlfriend
i really loved her and
i got to be honest with you as much as
an animal as i am
the first four years i was with her i
treated her with pretty much cotton
gloves
i kept her out of my affairs
because i didn't want her to be in my
world
at no
but when i got the longest yard
that's
when i woke up one morning and my
football uniform was laid out for me at
4 15 in the morning she's doing dion
sanders [__] for you jesus christ i used
to do is lay out the socks at all
you know she didn't laugh
but the jersey the pants it's out there
and i just looked at her one day and i
go you you know like i didn't even say
nothing who what woman if you go home
now and tell you a woman that you have
an argument they're thinking of leaving
you
if you do something wrong in a
relationship
a woman will [__] leave you in a
heartbeat you know like the way my wife
left me in 91 you know
uh
i don't know with terry it seemed like
when i got the longest yard and i saw
that close out
i was like okay
this is my girl
now i gotta figure out
how i'm gonna keep her
you know that was
by the time 2003 2004 came i was pretty
busy with movies i had done spider-man 2
you got nothing i did a bunch of films
and my stand-up i was opening for rogan
so things were going on
the only thing that was really really
holding me back was my cocaine addiction
and i'll never forget that one night i
had to call her to come get me on a
[__] monday morning
you know when i left saturday night i
got dragged in by these dudes at the
store
and we went to their house in hollywood
and we did coke
we did everything
and that
eight in the morning on a monday i had
to call my wife
and tell her pick me up by
fairfax
by the starbucks there and across from
that breakfast joint
and i'll never forget i was so
embarrassed i was on a two-day binge i
was foaming at the mount
she drove me home she put me in bed you
know i barked
she understood
and i was so [__] embarrassed and i
remember two i slept for two days after
that run
and i'll never forget getting in her car
to drive and a light just puking
out the door yeah three days later
though i covered my hand when the puke
started
but all those things attributed to me
like i had to give her a chance
i couldn't [__] her over
like i could not end it like i ended all
my other relationships
that was not gonna happen we were not
gonna end up
like her picking my clothes up in jail
or something like you know i get
arrested and she's gotta bring my
clothes to jail so when i get out of
jail i basically got nowhere to live
like
that wasn't gonna get to that part with
her so i knew that
that i had to clean up my life i kept
doing coke guys i kept it away from her
but
over the years i could tell it was
starting to
affect her
and then she went home for her
brother's
babies
my my brother-in-law was gonna have his
first child
and my wife went back in like 2004
and when she came back
she was a little depressed
i could tell that
it was she wasn't herself
you know
she was getting older
and
she wanted a family
and we'll end it right there boom
i love you brother uh and that's two and
that's two thousand four hold on i wanna
timestamp that we're ending it two what
month what roughly what where are we at
august 2004 all right we're going to
pick up next time august 2004 i love you
brother you want to promote anything
no i got my shows are sold out at uh
uncle funny uncle vinnie's
down in point pleasant i got three more
shows left i'm gonna add some shows but
i got a uh residency
starting september 17th at the sony
theater i'll keep everybody afloat on
that [__] yeah good for you brother
yeah let's do this in two weeks or so
so we continue this story this is a good
story because this is a great one
this is one of my favorite episodes i
gotta say this this this time right here
is one of my favorites
this is when i started drawing in don't
get me wrong
i was still a [__] savage but i had
it in my mind that
this was all coming to an end soon
either ah what's the expression you got
a [__] or get off the box [__] or get
off the pop brother
that's the name of this episode
perfect
i love you and as always ryan sickler
dot com right and sick on all social
media we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you